- Good morning Believe Nation,
my name is Evan Carmichael
and my one word is "Believe" and I believe
that entrepreneurs are going
to solve all of the world's
major problems.
So to help you on your journey
today, we're going to learn
how to have fun.
Over to you, Hugh Jackman.
(rooster crowing)
(groovy music)
- When the things most
matter, you so desperately
don't want to destroy it for being scared
that you can really destroy it.
When I hosted the Oscars, I was like
"Wow man, this is a billion
people", and I just thought,
"Okay, whatever you do
just remember you're
"a kid form Moringa in Sydney,
you're hosting the Oscars,
"have some fun", you
know and, luckily for me,
those turning points, I've
somehow always stuck to that idea
of just having fun.
- If you're not having fun,
you're never going to shine.
If you're not having fun and
you're constantly stressed
and you're constantly
worried and you're constantly
freaking out, then you're
not going to have fun,
your customers aren't going to have fun,
your suppliers aren't going to have fun,
and you're never going to be
able to build the business
that you want to build.
I think you have to attack
it from both sides where
you want to build a better
future, you want to be upset
about what you've created,
and you want to build
something greater.
And at the same time have
fun, and be grateful,
and recognize all the
amazing things that you have
currently built up.
It's both.
If all you're doing is fun,
happy, la la la and you never
strive to improve, and
if all you're focusing on
is improvement and getting
better then you're never happy.
You need to have both.
One of the things that I've
encouraged my instructors
here to do at Toronto
Dance Salsa is to have fun
in their class.
And their students will have fun,
our customers will have
fun if the instructor
is genuinely having fun.
And that looks different
for different people.
One instructor might tell
a lot of silly jokes,
one instructor might
be goofy at the front,
one instructor might put on a song
that makes him really happy.
It doesn't matter what it
is, it has to be individual
to each person and I
can't tell that person
"Here's what you need
to do to have more fun",
they already know.
But for their class to be more fun,
they have to actually be
having fun in the class.
And so if you take that to your business,
yes you want to strive,
yes you want to grow,
yes you want to push,
yes you want the best,
yes you want to improve,
and, at the same time,
you want to enjoy what you
have, you want to have fun,
you want to be grateful,
and you want to remember
this moment as something
special in history.
Sometimes it can be hard
to remember to do it
but even just a simple reminder can help.
If you feel yourself
getting really stressed out,
freaking out, not being
clear, snapping at people,
just a reminder to say,
"How can I have a little
more fun in this?"
or, "What am I grateful for today?" Or,
"How can I make this situation better?"
to cool yourself down, gain
a little more perspective,
and help you go off and
accomplish the big goals
that you've set for yourself.
So the question today is,
I'm curious what do you do
in your business to have a little fun?
Leave it down in the comments below,
super curious to find out.
I also want to give a
quick shoutout to Shoaib,
I hope I pronounced that
okay, from hmshost.com.
Thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book
"Your One Word", I really appreciate it
and I hope you're enjoying reading it.
So thank you guys again for
watching, I believe in you.
Ii hope you continue
to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love and I will see
you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of entspresso.
(groovy music)
- [Reporter] So something like
Avengers, it seems like you
were having a great time.
- I am.
- [Reporter] Not a huge
acting challenge for you,
I'd imagine, but-
- That depends.
[Reporter] You seem to be having fun.
- Well fun is important,
this should be a fun job.
It's make believe.
It's you and your friends
with real costumes
and better guns and
(muted) doing the thing,
exciting people.
That's what that's about.
When you're doing something
like The Avengers,
you got to take it seriously in terms of
you believe the space you're
in, you believe the world
and the convention of it, that
there are people who can do
(muted) greater than
normal human beings can do.
Trust that, go with it,
treat them like they're those
kinds of people and they
have an element of danger
and an element of awe
that comes with all that.
That's the honesty of the world.
But I'm (muted) Nick Fury, I
got some (muted) with me, too.
So I can be, you know, boom.
I can stand up to them
and say what I need to say
and sometimes, like in The
Avengers, I need to manipulate
these people, I got to
where I an because I'm
Nick (muted) Fury, I can do some (muted).
Nobody know how old I am
or why I'm still alive.
Or why I'm now black
when I used to be white.
So I got some (muted) with me too.
So you could accept that and
you go with it and you treat it
like it's something
honest and you treat it
like it's something real so
when people come and see it,
they don't see you going
(snorts)
you know, I'm in it.
I'm in it, its some
dangerous (muted) happening
and you (muted) can help us fix that.
So lets go get 'em, you
and your friends doing
that (muted) when you're kids.
"Lets go get 'em, lets go get 'em".
And then you shoot a (muted)
and they can't say you missed.
Cause the chest blow up and all that kind
of (muted) happens, it's great.
- So even with these
movies under your belt,
you came out to L.A. and
you're still thinking
it was going to be for P.A. work.
- I still thought it was
going to be P.A. work.
I mean I didn't know, still...
I was believing more, I
mean, I shouldn't like
that I was doing it and I had people,
and I couldn't, honestly at that time,
the 328 hours I was like,
"Is this legal?"
Cause it was so much fun and I was
(laughter)
I was really looking over
my shoulder going "Hmm".
(laughter)
And I kept getting invited back.
And then I had people coming up going,
"Hey man, you're good
at this" and I was like,
"Well thanks cause it sure is fun".
So I really didn't know,
I guess secretly, if I look
back and I look at my diaries,
there was hope underlined
but I was still like
I needed to go out and get
a job and if I could pursue
acting on the side.
Get a P.A. job, get the story
telling biz behind the camera
and let's see.
Then another funny thing happened.
That first audition when I got out here
was for a caster called Hank McCahn.
Know who I'm talking about?
It was for a film called
"Boys in the Side".
And I went and read and he
goes, "You did really good,
"I'll have you for a call
back sometime later".
I went off from there, I get called in
for a baseball film,
"Angels in the Outfield".
I walk in the door.
There's a bunch of funny peculiarities.
How the hell I got to standing here today?
I walk in the door to this
back lid, I remember I had
an American cap on, it was
on Warner Brother's lab,
I open up the door, it was
back lit in the afternoon,
the producer is sitting on the
couch, he looks up and goes,
"Hey it's Jimmy, the All-American kid.
"You ever play baseball?"
I said "12 years", he says,
"You got the job".
(laughter and applause)
So they said to me they're
paying me Schedule-F, 48.5.
$48,500 to go play baseball
for eleven weeks in Oakland,
again I'm going "What is this business?".
But it happened and during
that I got called back
to read for Herbert
Ross' "Boys on the Side"
and got that role so
that Cohen Brother's film
that got pushed, that P.A.
job that I would've taken
if it was there and it never happened.
I have a P.A. stand.
(laughter)
(disco music)
- By the way, I believe
in winners and losers
and especially the freedom to fail.
- (both) Who him? Me? Who?
(disco music)
- No way!
- Have fun!
You're not going to have fun
every minute of every day,
I'd dont care what job you take, you know.
Any job you take, I don't care
how well rewarded you are,
I don't care anything about
that, it won't happen all
the time but you better be
having fun in what you do.
The truth is a lot of success
won't just come from ideas
and being hardcore and
being in the weight room.
A lot of your success is
going to come from luck.
I know that was true in my
case and I know, frankly,
it's the case of almost
every successful entrepreneur
I met in the tech business
in the last 34 years.
People will make it seem like
it was the grandmaster plan
and all cases of an all knowing
and an all seeing genius,
that and a lot of luck is
what really leads to success.
So given that you're going
to have to have a lot luck,
you better be having a lot of fun.
Don't take the next job or
don't do the next start-up
because you "should", do
it because you want to.
Because you can think of
nothing better, more exciting,
more energizing to get
up every day and go do
the whatever it is that you selected.
Be patient when you get the
first signs that it's not fun
because time must be measured.
Constantly be improving yourself.
Cause only by improving
yourself will you maybe
find that next idea.
I'm sure there are many
people in this audience
who'd like to do a start up.
And yet, first of all to do a start up,
is you got to have an idea.
But if you're having fun, if
you're building capabilities,
if you're treasuring your
time, if you're building
your muscle and being hardcore,
the good ideas will come to you.